- First of all, thank you so much for
what you're doing for us.
We, I mean, I've always appreciated it
but obviously we all
appreciate it way more now.
(inspiring music)
- We talk about nurses,
other people that are
that make our entire country
work, our entire society work.
- Yeah.
- And we ought to be so grateful to them
for persisting and persevering
through all these challenges
and doing their best for our young people.
- I'm a neonatal intensive care nurse,
And so I've seen firsthand
moms being separated
from their babies.
And so
that was tough, and is still tough for me.
- So I'm a nurse at
Fox Chase Cancer Center
And this started when a patient came in
with a young patient with
metastatic disease and he was
in so much pain and it was
his birthday and he was alone.
Couldn't have family here with him
and I just felt the need
to give him something
and celebrate his birthday.
- And so my mom actually
grabbed a trash bag
and was just triaging patients basically
and writing down what
medications do you need?
Because imagine someone who
is elder and needs oxygen.
How could they run out of that fire,
grabbing their oxygen
tank or their medications.
- We value your dedication,
your service, everything.
So on behalf of our show
I wanna present to you with this check.
The show is donating 5,000.
I'm gonna donate 15.
And we love what you're doing
and we wanna see you keep doing it.
So that's why we're just
gonna give you $2,500
just to help out.
- Oh my God that's awesome.
- We're gonna send all
of you on a five day trip
to Westgate Town Center Resort in Orlando.
Would you be into this kind of vacation?
- Oh yeah.
(laughing)
(inspiring music)